pour accéder à la collection il faut
monter tout en haut du château jusqu'à
cette salle où le temps s'est arrêté
fossil cristaux morceaux de roche
certains objets datent de la préhistoire
comme sept dents de mammouth
incroyablement bien conservée pour ses
cinquante mille ans 28 cm de long 5 kg
sur la balance ici les techniciens
nettoie et enregistre minutieusement
chaque objet avant de les stocker en
salle est préservée de la lumière dans
des bacs aveugle
et là la ficelle elle même est une
ficelle pacifique imputrescible pas
d'entendre la tâche est colossale il
faut retrouver l'identité de 33000 l'eau
tous issus de la collection du muséum
d'histoire naturelle de blois il se met
y est ici depuis la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale
mises à l'abri dans l'urgence pour ne
pas qu'elles soient bombardées ça n'a
pas besoin de plus certaines de 1940
qui
s'échappe
on découvre qu est ce que ça te
voilà une petite roche avec son
étiquette ancien
conglomérat degrés
il ya des précisions ça vient de baden
baden donc en allemagne là j'ai des
crampes bridge et quelques histoires
petit à petit plus je cherche trouve
évidemment mais là on va vraiment
pouvoir faire beaucoup plus de
découvertes et aussi comblé tous les
petits trous qu'on a dans l'histoire du
muséum un peu plus loin hugo qui pilote
le projet découvre une taxidermie d'une
centaine d'années une antilope venus
d'inde on va mettre un masque de
spécifier pour les les poussières fines
compte rendu des saints tel qu'un père
de quoi mais globalement elle est pas
mal en parfaite état mais toxiques comme
la plupart des objets conservés à
l'époque dans des produits aujourd'hui
interdite au sens large dans les
collections d'histoire naturelle il ya
toujours des polluants donc les
taxidermie il ya des métaux lourds de
l'arsenic qui était à la base pour
repousser les les infestations le formol
peut être est un solvant et c'est un cmr
cancérigènes mutagènes reprotoxiques
il faudra cinq ans à hugo et son équipe
pour terminer l'inventaire le public et
les chercheurs du monde entier pourront
alors consulter cette banque de données
certains objets resteront stockés
d'autres seront exposées dans les musées
de toute la france